well I'm delighted to be joined in the
studio now by the chair the Home Affairs
Select Committee Labour's Yvette Cooper
hello morning good to be with you so
what's your reaction then to the
election results when you lost didn't
you but at the same time quite a good
result for labour yeah and we saw I
think great to see all these
constituencies turning labour again to
see at more Labour MPs being elected I
think we had a very strong campaign and
Jeremy's work across the country did a
lot to inspire young people coming out
to vote and that's really important not
just for this election but it feels
really important for the health of our
democracy to see more people voting and
particularly more young people having
their say the same time that you lost
for the third time you got fewer seats
than you did in previous elections over
the last election but it's not really in
the incredible result that jeremy
corbyn's been hailing has it I mean is
this how far the Labour Party's sunk now
but losing an election this victory well
we've got to go further of course we
have and you know it's great to see us
win seats like Canterbury or Kensington
and Chelsea which we wouldn't imagine
winning in this election but of course
we've also got to look at what do we
need to do to win back Mansfield that we
lost some a small number of
constituencies that we lost and I don't
think there'll be any sense of a
complacency anywhere in the party
because we're going to need to do more
and win more seats but also recognise
that actually that increase in turnout
having the young voters come out was
really important and everybody should
welcome that at the same time as saying
of course we all want to do more you
were up against probably the worst
conservative campaign that many of us
can remember they weren't you that's
true or if they get there any together
then you could be looking at losing a
lot more seat look trees most campaign
unraveled very substantially and she had
a poor manifesto manifesto I think you
know provoked actually strong support
has provoked actually a lot of hostility
as well I think look there's three
challenges for labour right now the
first is we have got to keep challenging
to resume and this deeply dodgy DUP deal
because I think it goes against what the
election result was I think you know
treasom a held a referendum on herself
and lost it so the idea that she can
just carry on as
the election didn't happen simply
through this dodgy deal I think is not
on secondly I think we have to find a
way to get some cross-party consensus
around a stable brexit process and
negotiation process because otherwise
that's going to get caught up in chaos
and that won't be in the national
interest and then thirdly I think we're
going to have to prepare for another
general election because whilst I don't
think it's what a lot of people want and
certainly be a lot of very tired
candidates and party members of all
kinds feeling you know rolling their
eyes at the thought I just don't see
that what Tereza Mays doing is
sustainable so therefore we have to be
ready for whatever comes at us and
should Jeremy Corbyn leave the Labour
Party into that and of course so you've
got him wrong then denier well I think
since the leadership election last
summer actually the whole party has been
pulling behind Jeremy and Tom and the
Shadow Cabinet and so on so yeah it's
right we had leadership elections last
summer and the summer before and we had
a debate as part of that but since then
everybody's been pulling together and I
think that's why you know actually we
had that strong results as a result of
not just the work that Jeremy and the
campaign team were doing nationally but
also the hard work of a lot of local
candidates a lot of local party members
some very targeted campaigns in
different areas as well so it was the
fact of the whole party is what's
delivered you know the progress that
we've made but you're right we still got
to go further let's have a look at what
you did say last summer about Jeremy
Corbyn he's losing his labour support
across the country particularly in the
towns and coalfield that built the
labour movement I mean do you accept
that you were wrong well that was what I
was worried about at the time of the
referendum I think it was in a slope
exactly because that's what we were all
worried about at the time of the
referendum and I think you know you can
see the contrast between really the
campaign that we had during the
referendum and the campaign that we've
had since then so I think the campaign
now is very different and actually as a
result of everybody supporting it last
summer after the referendum I think we
were all deeply troubled about what was
happening not just in coal fields but in
towns across the country what I think we
do have now there
is it is a bit there is a bit of a
difference between areas particularly
London and the cities where we've had
really strong support and a big increase
in majorities big turnout and so on and
of course places like Mansfield which is
a coal field area in the East Midlands
where actually we lost the the
constituency there so it's incumbent on
all of us you know right through in
terms of the leadership the Shadow
Cabinet and the whole party to look at
what we do now to build on those gains
in those constituencies as well as a
look at the areas look where were we
lost and we need to pull that back I'm
still a bit confused but if you think
you were wrong about Jeremy Corbyn or
not well I think that if things have
changed since then and I think what we
accepted was we had a leadership
election after the summer at the end of
that leadership election we all said
okay it's done we've had that debate
Jeremy won that second leadership
election and he has just shown why he
won that second leadership election
because he emerged to inspire the Labour
Party during last summer and then also
has managed to inspire a lot of people
to go out and vote labour this during
this election as well but I do think
circumstances have also changed the
referendum last camp last year I think
was look was really troubling for a lot
of us we've changed a lot the party has
changed a lot and the party has moved on
a lot since then and that's why we had
such a strong campaign right now you
talked about the party pulling together
so if you were offered a job now in the
chera cabinet would you take it I'm not
going to be presumptuous about what
Jeremy wants to do it is his decision
about what he wants to do in terms of
the Shadow Cabinet and you know he's got
to choose the Shadow Cabinet he wants
that's what I think he did last autumn
you know what he asked me to do was to
do the refugee task force which I did
and where we got the Dobbs amendment
through as a result which was I think
really important as it helped a lot of
child refugees so well I know it's a
hypothetical question all politicians
hate those but what if he did pick up
the phone and say you bet I wouldn't
have you back on my top table what you
say yeah I think again I don't think I
should be presumptuous and I don't think
we should get into a kind of anything
anybody should be bartering or bidding
for different kinds of jobs in TV
studios and I
I think Jeremy would be setting out his
shadow cabinet in TVC Julio's either
he's he's not asked me ever before to be
in his shadow cabinet I've been doing
their home Affairs Select Committee he's
got to decide what he wants to do and
then other people can respond to that I
think the bigger point is the principle
that we all need to be pulling together
to take on to resume and to take on the
Tories and what they're doing this DUP
deal that they have done is really dodgy
it's unsustainable but it's not just bad
in terms of the politics of the House of
Commons it's also really irresponsible
for the Northern Ireland peace process
and the idea that the British government
could be taking sides having been the
guarantor of the Good Friday Agreement
and the subsequent peace agreements I
think is really troubling and you know
there's been a lot of criticism both for
Theresa May and for David Cameron of
putting their party interest above the
national interest both in terms of the
referendum without a plan then in terms
of this general election without a plan
actually think that they're doing it a
third time now they're putting party
interest in terms of cobbling together
their government ahead of the national
interest and the Northern Ireland peace
process and its really really worrying
but genuine question what could the
Conservatives do now what choice does
trees may have because she doesn't have
the numbers to have a majority
government what's she supposed to do I
don't think her position is tenable at
all I think she made this election all
about herself and has had such a strong
reaction against her and against the the
decisions that she put forward so I
don't think her position is tenable I
also don't think that she's got the
skills to cope with a hung parliament
where you have to work in a different
way you have to be more collegiate you
have to be more open and transparent you
have to work with other parties and I
can't see how having the skills to do
that at all so that I assume they will
have a leadership contest within the
Conservative Party and you think that's
right I think it's not for me to judge
what's the right thing for to do for
them I think I assume that's where they
will end up because I don't see that
Teresa Mays position is remotely tenable
I also just don't think she's going to
be capable of doing the very difficult
cross party work that's needed in a hung
parliament got more seats and more votes
than Jeremy Corbyn and you're saying her
positions untenable
so why is jeremy corbyn's tenable then
because he got diverse and he what he
saw the was there was an increase in the
number of seats and an increase in labor
support and a lot yeah and you know
we've got to do more we've got to do a
lot more I suppose you could sort of see
it as a it's like Theresa May has ended
up creating both a coalition of chaos
and stable and strong leadership but
only from the opposite parties of the
ones that she intended to I think the
big challenge for us is actually now
about the brexit negotiations there's
not a lot we can do about the chaos in
the Conservative Party at the moment but
we've got article 50 has been triggered
and there needs to be some sort of
brexit negotiation process take place
I've always said I thought that that
should be done as a cross-party process
I think now there should be a sort of
cross party commission or group set up
to try and take forward those
negotiations in a way that is open that
is thoughtful that is consensual that
accepts that not everybody is going to
get the deal they want you know there's
going to have to be compromises on all
sides but if you try and do it in that
way we might actually be able to pursue
the national interest rather than it
just getting you know stuck in this Tory
small cabal which is what Teresa wants
and is simply not going to work you talk
about the brexit negotiations that are
looming very difficult talks a big
responsibility for a divided Parliament
this is a time when surely Jeremy Corbyn
needs his top team around him there's
been reports saying that he'd be
prepared to let some of those big beast
on the back benchers back into the
shadow cabinet if they wholeheartedly
back the manifesto I mean is that
something that you'd be prepared to do
do fully stand behind that manifesto we
have had a good manifesto that's built a
lot of support all across the country
not just things like the support for the
NHS but things like the lifelong
learning that nobody really noticed
because it got so ended up getting
caught up on different issues and
debates actually there's some really
important policies within that manifesto
that we have to keep campaigning for a
little bit then D but I think your your
point was still trying to kind of suck
me back into advising Jeremy Corbyn on
the Shadow Cabinet that he should do and
that is not for me to do he's got to
make his decisions as he
done every single time before what we've
got to do as a Labour Party is
concentrate I think on those three
things challenging to resume and and on
the DUP deal trying to get a cross-party
stable process around the brexit
negotiations and then preparing for what
could end up being another general
election at any time where actually we
are going to need to be as forceful and
as determined in taking the Tories on
and stopping them doing the things they
wanted to do the school cuts that they
wanted to do that hit a kids future the
hit to the NHS the hit to families
across the country who actually need a
Labour government standing up for them
and that is what we have to keep working
for it feels like at the moment the
Labour Party is really shaped in jeremy
corbyn's image I mean that manifesto had
his fingerprints all over it had the
Labour moderates the critics of Jeremy
Corbyn effectively lost the argument now
I think there's broad consensus behind
that manifesto you know what you're
talking about is investing in public
services what you know it then it also
includes I mean Jeremy Corbyn has
accepted the rest of the Labour Party's
position on Trident you know so actually
I think there was always there would be
review and he wouldn't commit to
everything yeah the manifesto it was
very clear the party policy has been
very clear we continue being a
multilateral Esparta not a unilateralis
party so look there are going to carry
on being differences of view on
different policies but that's okay you
know we can still be a broad-based party
and I think that actually what we ran
during this election campaign was a very
broad-based campaign and that is how we
did get support from different parts of
the country how we managed to win back
support from you kick voters and also
win back support from Liberal Democrat
voters and get new voters coming to us
and you know we had some areas where we
had former Tory voters who are upset
about the dementia tax so I think it was
broad-based you're right it didn't go
far enough in terms of winning a Labour
majority and that is our challenge now
and so we do need to look at okay what
more do we need to do if we're to win
back Mansfield if we're to win back the
extra votes that we need what do we need
to do to build on this not simply to
kind of rest on our laurels and think
this is far enough it's it's go further
oK you've got keeper thanks very much
for
jeepers today